did you see [ __ ] zuckerberg do the
shoot that arrow
people are like i don't understand is he
trying to make [ __ ] seem like
he's a robot
i mean in the in the thing when he was
in front of where what was a congress or
whatever and he was just like
hello i am mark
zuckerberg have you ever tried to thwart
and suppress certain posts
when it comes to political parties
no i'm mark
zuckerberg
i am mark zuckerberg i like to make
hamburgers did you see that one thing
that one video
where he was trying to [ __ ] i love
beef
like how could you be more
robot then i love beef
i love burgers and i love grilling
[Laughter]
let me let me bring it up mark
zuckerberg
bergberg dude zuckerberg smoking meat
here we go
here we go stay insecure the whole thing
by the way
hey everyone we are so i've never seen
somebody i have actually
never seen somebody act more insecure
than mark zuckerberg
bro it is insane but listen hello
everybody
i love smoked meats and you can tell
because i have two smokers behind me
why is he sitting on [ __ ] lawn chairs
like dude aren't you
[ __ ] stacked
he starts it with we are live from my
backyard
where i am smoking a brisket and some
ribs
i am i'm making meats now smoking these
meats here
are a little meat smoking it's smoking
so
i'm the meat chef yeah someone asked me
do i smoke meat
smoking meat smoking these meats smoking
meats earlier in the day
smoking these meats just set the
charcoal up and you set the
the wood chips up and then smoking meats
really grilling meats
good smoky flavor smoke a brisket for
like 12 hours
you smoke lemon chicken smoked salmon
you'll love it
bison sirloin ribs and sausage so i'm
looking forward to that
just so insecure today we got a brisket
on the big guy oh on the big guy pork
ribs
on on on the green eggs and secure
who are the other two guys that are the
same guys are they the new winklevoss
twins
winklevoss i smoke meats hello i smoked
meats
i grilled i grill and i smoke meats i
smoked
salmon and meats meats
you know can you get more specific
salmon what yes i am
regular i have two bread i have two
smokers in the back
the big guy and the less big guy
i smoke meats can you be more specific
yes i smoke meats
salmon
i am mark zuckerberg have you ever
[ __ ] tried to suppress political
meats have you ever tried to
did you try to change the outcome of the
election i smoke
meats what kind
salmon meats
but hopefully for canadian thanksgiving
you get to eat a lot of brisket and ribs
how many of you guys are eating brisket
and ribs tonight
brisket and and ribs i mean
just [ __ ] saying brisket so much
brisket what kind of meats
brisk cut brisket salmon and
ribs that shit's on patreon go check it
out